hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played in 2012 it's
the second round of a very strong
tournament uh the fifth Grand Slam chess
final it was played a half of the
tournament was held in in Brazil in Sao
Paulo in half of the tournament in
Bilbao in Spain and uh well you guys
have requested this game for quite some
time now and I thought okay tomorrow the
World Cup is starting I have no idea
what to show uh you guys suggest so much
uh so I thought okay let's uh this one
I've been postponing for a very long
time and it's uh it's younger Magnus so
a pre-World Championship era Magnus it's
2012 Magnus uh defeated the vishwanathan
in 2013 uh to win his World Series
championship title but you can see how
uh easily he will uh make this game look
even though you know the Queens get
traded off right away and it's a very
short game but just the end game is by
far superior and how you can't just play
normal moves and think you will you will
achieve some something with white so
that being said let's check it out we
have pawned the E4 his opponent is the
very strong Francisco Vallejo pons also
goes by Paco Vallejo we have D6 D4 and
now Knight to F6 Magnus goes for appears
defense we have Knight to C3 and pawn to
E5 and usually Knight to F3 is what is
played here but here we have D captures
on E5 going for the early Queen trade d
captures Queen capture 78 and King
characters and now today Bishop to C4 if
this is even played in Bishop to G5 are
the main moves but here we have Knight
to F3
uh and the bishop to D6 with Bishop to
G5 Bishop to E6 and now Queen side
Castle so wine has very very natural
development but you don't really gain
all that much yes Magnus
um uh cannot Castle but he doesn't want
his King will be perfectly fine in the
center of the board Knight the D7 and
now Knight to B5 going after the bishop
Fair Magnus says all right King E7
Knight capture C captures and now Bishop
to B5 so now uh Magnus lost the bishop
pair but what can uh what can Paco do
with with his Bishop pair we have Rook H
to d8 and it is now as of move 11 that
this position has never been reached
again so now it is a completely unique
game uh of course you know that H6 is
coming uh the only reason Magnus cannot
capture on e4 is because the Knight is
pencil he will of course play H6 G5 kick
away the bishop and then win the E4 Pawn
so a paco needs to defend the pawn
Knight to D2 he wants to further
strengthen the center with Pawn to F3
and Magnus starts chasing with the
battle H6 Bishop to H4 and pawn to G5 we
have Bishop to G3 and pawn to A6 kicking
away the other Bishop as well
uh and here you could play something
like Bishop D2 but he decides for Bishop
captures on D7 so pretty much just
trading uh all the pieces with Rook
captures on D7 and pawn to F3 this Earth
uh strengthens the D for pawn and now
you don't have to keep your knight on D2
We have Rook to C8 and now King the B1
makes sense as The Rook is on the C file
uh Knight to H5 and while you could play
something like Bishop to F2 uh then the
Knight comes to F4 attacks the G2 Pawn
you have to push it then you go here
attack the bishop and the uh Black's
moves are are you know just uh a very
very natural and come very quickly so
instead Francisco played uh Knight to F1
and now Magnus goes Pawn to F5 we have e
captures on F5 Bishop capture is now
putting pressure on that C2 pawn and you
have to defend Knight to E3 attacks and
defense uh Bishop to G6 and now Rook to
D to adding another Defender to the C2
Pawn we have King the E6 and now Pawn to
B3 uh trying to get the king to B2 so
you can advance the pawn to C4 and
Magnus of course stops this with Pawn to
B5 now he has very nice control over the
C4 square and even though Paco does have
control over the D5 Square it's not
really uh in any kind of real control so
King B2 and Magnus immediately advances
it to D5 so you can see how Magnus
didn't really do anything here in this
game he pretty much played all the force
moves he played whatever he could as uh
Paco uh forced all of the lines and he
now has a superior end game the material
is equal yes but look at magnus's
central control here and we all know
uh the old thing in chess as it goes he
who controls the center will be
victorious in the end uh Rook to E1 and
now Magnus goes Knight captures on G3
and it makes sense as the E5 Pawn could
come under Fire so Knight captures age
captures and now beautiful move Pawn to
H5 and now okay again material is equal
um uh Francisco's pawns are doubled here
on the G file and we have pawned the C3
now stopping any B4 or D for ideas but
not really Pawn to D4 C captures on D4
and now Rook captures this is the
uh correct way to capture if you capture
right away then this will be a problem
Knight the G4 will win the game for
white you will either have to go in
front of the pawn or you go up the board
and knights the E5 check picks up the
Rook or you go here and then it's a nice
mating one so you don't want to do that
but Magnus plays it correctly he plays C
captures uh first Rook captures on the
four and after Rook captures only now e
captures on D4
and it seems like uh you still have some
discoveries they're just not as potent
so Knights the C2 with track King to D5
and not Knights the B for with check and
Magnus goes King to D6 of course King to
C5 would be a terrible mistake Rook the
C1 would pick up the rook and C8 so King
to D6 and now comes Rook to C1 with Rook
to D1 uh you can still fight but after
Rook to C1 uh it's a very very
instructive how Magnus completely takes
over the game Rook captures on C1 King
characters and now what do you think
Magnus played here now I'm not gonna ask
you to pause the video because I have a
different move where I will ask you to
pause the video he played Ponte H4 and
what does this move on the other side of
the board do well it uh paralyzes the G2
pawn and the Magnus wants this Pawn
stuck here on the light Square so now
okay you should play something like
Knight back to C2 and try to hold the
position uh but uh Francisco tried to
grab a pawn G captures G captures and
now Knight captures on A6 so now is up a
pawn the problem is there's no way to
guard G2 Bishop to D3 now Bishop to F1
will be played and you cannot capture
the pawn that's why this H4 move was uh
so so strong Knight back to B4 now he
also wants to play A4 create a pass Pawn
on the queen side and Advance his own
phone to Victory the problem is Magnus
will have two
uh fast pawns the d-pawn and the H Pawn
so Bishop back to F1 King to D2 and
Bishop captures on G2 we have King to E2
defending the F3 Pawn but now feel free
to pause the video and try to find the
only move that wins the game for Magnus
while I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh wonderful a wonderful move and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Bishop to H3 that's the only
move and I'm sure you guys figure it out
so congratulations uh the way you figure
it out is that of course you want to
start advancing your pass Pawn but if
you play H3 after King to F2 uh there's
no way to continue advancing your past
spawn so after this King T2
sorry about that after this King T2
Bishop to H3 and that's pretty much it
A4 was played uh Bishop to F5 and now a
captures
um on B5 grabbing the pawn but now D3
check of course you cannot trade because
captures captures captures and then the
king is too far away to stop the past H
Pawn so King the E3 was played with H3
and not Knight captures on D3 Bishop
captures and he was in this position on
move 41 that Magnus Carlsen uh not Max
Carlson that Francisco uh resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here for those of you who enjoy it when
I finish the games uh the reason is
after you play anything uh the pawns
will just quickly come off the board
after the king attacks the pawn the
bishop will defend it and now the black
king will simply pick up this Pawn then
pick up this pawn and that's pretty much
it you can
uh we can fast forward to that at some
point the white king will have will be
forced into the corner you will waste
the move with something like Bishop to
G4 and after King to G1 H to check King
H1 and Bishop to F3 will be Checkmate so
there you have it of course uh both of
them knew this and he resigned here and
a very nice victory for Magnus Carlsen
so you see you can't just play anything
even though the moves are fine by the
engine uh it's just not a very it it's
it nothing good happens if you try to
play uh for a draw with the white pieces
even though it's a pre-World
Championship Magnus Carlsen you can see
that he took advantage of it and that
there there was absolutely nothing you
could do there and regarding the
standings at these sorry not these uh
let me just uh fix that
uh regarding the standings uh it was uh
as it was a six player double round
robin uh Magnus uh was tied in the end
with Fabiana corvana uh there we have it
uh I know I have them somewhere yeah and
he was tied in the end with Fabiano
Corona uh he went into tie breaks and
then he defeated Fabi both of the games
they played in the tie breaks uh but
yeah and also it was a you can see the
special scoring was in effect three
points per win and the only one point
per draw uh and they had the same four
wins one draw and uh no four wins uh one
loss and five draws then you had LaVon
in third Sergey kayaking in fourth fifth
and uh in in sixth place but yeah uh
very very instructive and that's why
when you even even though if you're
playing against a stronger opponent or I
don't know if Francisco considered
Magnus to be a stronger opponent then
probably he did as there was quite a bit
of a uh rating differences you can see
those were those are the actual ratings
I found them online 26.97 to Magnus is
28.43 so uh definitely a huge difference
but yeah you you just don't to go for
this queen trade and try to push for
something it's uh uh not definitely not
the way to go and don't try that in your
own games uh but yeah very nicely very
nicely done by Magnus and uh yeah I
really really hope you guys enjoyed this
I would like to thank Christoph Mark the
animated chemist an anonymous person uh
old games are best in Lane Herbert for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon starting tomorrow at
the World Cup will take place so if you
guys have any favorite games do you use
hashtag suggestion and I will definitely
go over them so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day